foreign
town of Boston Massachusetts Robert
welcome to the show
Hi how are you guys we are doing great
how can we help
thanks for taking my call
um so I'm 23 years old and I just paid
off my student loans in one year which
is twenty seven thousand dollars way to
go
thank you thank you so I have an I.T job
right now I'm making seventy thousand
dollars a year and with that I get a
401k and a four percent company match so
I put 10 in right now
um and I think that's looking pretty
good uh so I live at home with my
parents friend free right now and I pay
all my expenses and I have no debt other
than uh at all actually
um so I'm thinking of doing house
hacking and to move out eventually in a
couple years and I was wondering how I
should get started with that and what do
you guys think I need to save for that
how much do you have in savings right
now
um I have about 10 grand left over after
paying all my student loans and stuff
okay so let's call that your emergency
fund
yeah okay and you're investing 10
percent what does the company match
four percent
well if you're following the baby steps
are you a new listener to the plan
uh relatively okay so you would be a
what we call baby step four which is
invest fifteen percent of your income
into retirement so if I'm in your shoes
I'm bumping that up at 23 years old with
no debt and some money in the bank
you're in such an incredible financial
position
and you're wondering well where does
home ownership fall into this well that
would be baby step 3B is what we call
that saving up for that down payment on
a house and you can do this your own way
when it comes to 3B and four some people
like to invest all fifteen percent and
keep saving for the down payment some
people bring their investing down to
nothing to save for that down payment
more aggressively so in your shoes
you're young you could do that in order
to create some more margin but I
wouldn't touch that ten thousand let's
call that savings for emergencies
so now the next goal is how much is the
house that you are looking to buy this
duplex
um I haven't found anyone in particular
but I'm thinking around 200 000 to 400
000 that'd be my range have you actually
found duplexes for sale in the Boston
area in that range
um like ones that need Renovations and I
mean they're fixer-uppers
it doesn't sound like you're gonna have
money for renovations
um
because your plan is I'm gonna live on
one side and the renter is going to live
in the other and they're going to
magically pay my mortgage is that the
idea
yeah what are the values of duplexes in
these areas I mean do they hold their
value
typically because in the Boston area
that's very hard to get housing okay I
imagine there's people uh duplexes are
in high demand because of this idea that
you're talking about so I don't know
that you're going to find a deal on a
duplex unless it needs a lot of
Renovations and man at 23 with no money
that is a dangerous scenario because
what happens when the tenant doesn't pay
on time oh and by the way they live next
door and so anytime something happens
they're knocking on your door because
they know the landlord lives next door
oh that's awful and so I would just
tread with caution I know this is big
advice on tick tock on the financial
side of hey just house hack it's so easy
you can make so much money but man it is
so much more complicated than that and
it can be very risky is that what house
hacking is I I wasn't gonna ask but now
I don't care that's the idea I don't
know Robert did I sum it up well as to
what house hacking yeah so yeah okay we
get a duplex you know three fan four
family and you live in one unit and you
rent out the other ones which then
ideally pays for your mortgage and then
some do you want to live with your
renters that's a really boy you you
ought to do that on the talk George
because I think that would get some
views nobody wants my opinion there
because they're all wanting to make
money can they don't want to hear but
they're not thinking about living next
door to their renters and when something
goes wrong guess what
absolutely what happens if you don't get
back to them fast enough and they got
anger issues well when the HVAC goes I
could go on and it's on you to fix and
you to pay for and so that will that's
what worries me Robert is it sounds like
you're looking to put as little down to
get into this thing as possible on a
30-year in order to get the renter to
pay the other side
yeah and so our housing advice is a
15-year fixed rate mortgage because we
want you in debt for as little time as
possible and where the with the payment
is no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay and so if you can do that
and without having a tenant involved
then I would say you're financially
ready to to get that duplex or buy a
house
and that might mean you need to save up
you know 40 as a down payment instead of
five percent in order to make those
numbers work but it's it's not to be you
know super fundamental and go you're
doing it wrong if you don't do it this
way it's because of risk yeah and all
you see on paper is upside if you can
just do the crunch the numbers but
reality is a whole lot different so
Robert let me just let me flip this if
you knew that you could buy a home that
only you lived in
and you could pay it off quickly
and then reap the benefits of that very
Sound Investment much later in life
would you choose that or the housing
hack idea
well I was always thinking that I could
use the housing hack idea as an
investment in the future where when I'm
even on 30 I can move out of that and
have those two being rented and then buy
a house after that but I do like the
idea of maybe being able to pay off my
own house a lot quicker yeah and then
buy another then buy another house but
the point is you skip the whole idea
where you're a landlord
yeah you don't want to be a landlord you
just want to make money wisely that's
what I heard yeah am I correct
yeah I agree with that yeah so maybe we
we start looking at hey let's get a
condo for Robert that he can live in
maybe you want to get a roommate maybe
get a two bedroom condo and you can get
a roommate uh but I wouldn't go
investing in real estate until you've
got a paid for house yourself and you're
at a different place financially and
there's no rush man you're 23. who cares
if you get into this at 33 or 43.
everyone feels like I'm too late Ken if
I don't get into it but everyone there's
an 18 year old on Tick Tock who got
started and now he's making millions man
I think we got to get off I got a phrase
for you stop with the housing hacks stay
with the housing facts wow huh Robert
are you gonna tweet that nothing says
middle-aged man like that yeah they
don't like that on the talk no one likes
that yeah but it's a fact it's true well
it is yeah Robert I hope I hope that
helps I know I don't want to stomp on
your uh your parade there
and rain on it but I've just seen too
many situations where it doesn't go
according to plan like it did on paper
and The Tick Tock said it was going to
be easy and it would always work out and
life is just messy man so the best thing
you can do is walk into this thing with
patience with wisdom and with more money
than you think you need because it's
expensive